JUSTICE.
FINALLY IT HAS COME IN THIS
COUNTRY, AND YOU ONLY THE
BEGINNING.
THE RUSSIA COLLUSION HOAX HAS
BEEN BROUGHT TO ITS KNEES AND WE
HAVE MUCH MORE THAT WILL BE
COMING IN THE DAYS, WEEKS,
MONTHS TO FOLLOW.
THAT I CAN ASSURE YOU.
THE CONGENITAL LIAR, EVERYTHING
I’VE BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT HIM
IS TRUE.
HE IS NOW FACING PUBLIC
EMBARRASSMENT, HE MAY JUST NOT
KNOW IT YET.
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN
HAS BEEN EXONERATED, BY THE WAY
JUDGE SULLIVAN WHERE ARE YOU?
IT IS TIME TO LET THIS MAN GO
FREE.
WE NEED TO HEAR FROM YOU.
AND THE BIGGEST NEWS, FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA AS OF
YESTERDAY HAS BEEN IMPLICATED IN
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST ABUSE AND
POWER CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
SO BARACK JOE, WHAT DID BOTH OF
YOU KNOW AND WHEN DID YOU KNOW
IT?
WE NEED TO HEAR FROM YOU, AND
COMING UP WE WILL SHOW YOU ALL
OF THE EXPLOSIVE DEVELOPMENT
FROM THE INTEL COMMITTEE
DOCUMENTS.
HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF INTERVIEWS
THAT ADAM SCHIFF HAS BEEN HIDING
FROM THE PUBLIC BECAUSE THEY
REVEAL ALL OF HIS LIES.
WE WILL REVIEW HOW THE
PROPAGANDA ARM OF THE DEMOCRATIC
MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE
MEDIA MOB, SOCIALIST STATE TV,
HOW THEY ARE REACTING
DEFENSIVELY TO THIS WEEK’S
INCREDIBLE NEWS.
SPOILER ALERT, THE HYSTERIA HAS
NOW REACHED NEW HEIGHTS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE BEEN EXPOSED.
ALSO, WE HAVE A FULL REPORT ON
THIS HORRIFIC SHOOTING IN
GEORGIA.
YOU’VE SEEN THE VIDEOTAPE, WE
HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST, WE BEGIN ON THIS
FRIDAY NIGHT WITH THE CORRUPT,
THE COMPROMISE, THE CONGENITAL
LIAR ADAM SCHIFF.
HE HAS A NATIONAL DISGRACE, EVEN
WORSE THAN I THOUGHT.
THANKS TO ACTING NATIONAL INTEL
DIRECTOR CORNELL, THANKS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES BILL BARR, WE HAVE
DEFINITIVE PROOF OF SCHIFF’S
MALICIOUS DISHONESTY IN THE FORM
OF ROUGHLY 6,000 PAGES NEWLY
RELEASED, SWORN TESTIMONY HE HAS
BEEN HIDING FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THIS COMES FROM THE INTEL
COMMITTEES 2017 RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
THESE ARE THE INTERVIEWS THAT
WERE TAKEN UNDER OATH.
WE HAVE A COMPLETE TIMELINE OF
SCHIFF’S UNETHICAL BEHAVIOR,
OUTRIGHT LYING ON ALL OF THE
MEDIA, AND WE BEGIN.
LET’S START WITH THE DATE
JULY 17TH, 2017.
IT IS ON THAT DAY THAT ADAM
SCHIFF LISTENED TO OBAMA’S
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE.
THAT GUY IN THE MIDDLE, JAMES
CLAPPER.
HE TESTIFIED UNDER OATH SAYING
"I NEVER SAW ANY DIRECT
EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE THAT THE TERM
CAMPAIGN OR SOMEONE IN IT WAS
PLOTTING OR CONSPIRING WITH
RUSSIANS."
ON OCTOBER 13TH, SAME YEAR, HE
HEARD FROM OBAMA OFFICIALS
SAMANTHA POWER TESTIFIED SHE HAS
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
"I’M NOT IN POSSESSION OF
ANYTHING."
ON OCTOBER 8TH 2017, SUSAN RICE
TELLING ADAM SCHIFF "TO THE BEST
OF MY REFLECTION, THERE WASN’T
ANYTHING SMOKING.
I DON’T RECALL INTELLIGENCE THAT
I WOULD CONSIDER EVIDENCE TO
THAT EFFECT."
ON NOVEMBER 3RD, 2017, FORMER
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL SALLY
GATES SAYING TO ADAM SCHIFF
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BUT ON MARCH 132018,
FOUR MONTHS AFTER THOSE FOUR
OFFICIALS AND OTHERS
TESTIFIED, THERE WAS ZERO
EVIDENCE OF ANY TRAUMA OR RUSSIA
COLLUSION THE CONGENITAL LIAR
ADAM SCHIFF GOT IN FRONT OF A
CAMERA AND WAS HELD UP AS SOME
KIND OF HERO BY THE MOB MEDIA.
THE SOCIALIST MEDIA THAT SAID
THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE
OF TRUMPET RUSSIA COLLUSION.
HE KNEW IT WAS A LIE, HE HAD ALL
THE TESTIMONY PROVING IT WAS A
LIE, THIS IS WHAT HE TOLD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
WHETHER THE RUSSIANS STILL HAVE
SOMETHING THEY CAN HOLD OVER THE
PRESIDENT HAD.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
OUR WORK IS FAR FROM DONE.
I CAN SAY WITH CONFIDENCE THAT
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE CAMPAIGN
AND RUSSIA.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE A GUY THAT
WAS.
WHAT THE NATURE OF THE
COMPROMISE?
NAKED PICTURES.
DOES VLADIMIR KNOW?
VLADIMIR NO COMPROMISE.
THAT IS HIM ON TAPE, HE WAS
COLLUDING WITH A RUSSIAN HE
THOUGHT.
A YEAR LATER, BY THE WAY,
MARCH 24TH 2019 THERE IS SCHIFF
REPEATING HIS LIES AS HE HAD ALL
THROUGHOUT THIS TIME.
THEY NEVER, EVER CHALLENGE HIM,
THEY WERE GIDDY.
WELCOME BACK CONGRESSMAN,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
WE APPRECIATE YOU, WHAT NEWS,
WHAT LIES DO YOU TELL US AND WE
LET YOU GET AWAY WITH IT?
"ABC NEWS," TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU HAVE SAID IN THE PAST
THERE WAS SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION, HOW DO YOU SQUARE
THAT WITH ROBERT MUELLER’S
DECISION NOT TO INDICT ANYONE
QUESTION MIKE >> THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION, WE HAVE SAID THAT
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO INVITE HIM
BACK AND SAY WHY DID YOU LIKE TO
US?
ON APRIL 7TH 2019, AFTER THE
MUELLER REPORT FOUND NO EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION, THAT WAS THE
FOURTH INVESTIGATION.
SCHIFF CONTINUE TO LIE, HE’S
STILL LYING.
HE GOES ON FAKE JAKE NEWS
TOPPERS SUNDAY SHOW THAT NOBODY
WATCHES, AND HE SAID THERE WAS
AMPLE EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
THIS IS WHY PEOPLE CHANT CNN
SUCKS.
>> I SAID ON YOUR SHOW AND
OTHERS, JAKE, FOR OVER A YEAR
NOW IS THAT YES THERE IS AMPLE
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION IN PLAIN
SIGHT.
BUT THAT IS NOT THE SAME THING
AS PROOF OF A CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT.
>> Tucker:>> Sean: THAT IS THE G
REPRESENTED THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE.
RUSSIA RUSSIA RUSSIA, UKRAINE
UKRAINE UKRAINE.
THE CONGENITAL LIAR SCHIFF
DAMAGED THIS COUNTRY WITH ALL OF
THESE LIES, ONE HOAX AFTER
ANOTHER.
ALL THESE CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
THE MOB AND FOR MEDIA, YOU
PEOPLE IN THE MOB YOU ARE HIS
WILLING ACCOMPLICES.
YOU’VE BEEN HIS DUPE THE WHOLE
WAY.
LIE AFTER LIE, RUSSIAN LIES,
UKRAINIAN LIES, SCHIFF SHALL
LIES, HE IS LEADING HIS PARTY
AND THE MOB INTO WHAT ARE
UNCHARTED WATERS THAT LITERALLY
THREATEN THE CONSTITUTIONAL
ORDER OF THIS COUNTRY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS CREEPY
LOOKING LUNATIC WHO WILL DO AND
SAY ANYTHING TO SMEAR, SLANDER,
BESMIRCH DONALD TRUMP.
AND THRUST HIMSELF INTO THE
LIGHTS OF THE CAMERAS.
IN THE LIMELIGHT.
THIS LINE THAT YOU JUST
WITNESSED, ONLY THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
FOR EXAMPLE, I CAN GO ON THE
WHOLE SHOW.
NOVEMBER 15TH 2017, HE DEFENDED
HILLARY’S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION FROM THE
GET-GO, BECAUSE THE RUSSIANS
KNEW STEELE WAS FEEDING IT TO
HILARY.
WE ARE HELPING HILARY, CREATING
THE CHAOS DEVIN NUNES WARNED
OBAMA AND BIDEN ABOUT IN 2014
AND THEY DIDN’T LISTEN TO.
HE SAID THAT MUCH OF THE
DOCUMENT, MEANING THE DOSSIER,
PROVED TRUE.
THAT WAS ANOTHER LIE.
DECEMBER 19TH, 2017.
McCABE’S SWORN, THE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR COULD NOT POINT TO ONE
SINGLE CLAIM, NOT ONE, NOT ONE
IN A STEELE DOSSIER THAT HE KNEW
WAS TRUE AND ACCURATE, ALL OF
THAT IS IN THIS DOCUMENT.
THANKS TO RIC GRENELL AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR.
HE DIDN’T KNOW IF THE STEEL
MATERIAL ON CARTER PAGE, HE
DIDN’T KNOW IF ANY OF IT WAS
TRUE.
NONE OF IT WAS TRUE.
THE MATERIAL THAT WAS USED
STARTING IN OCTOBER OF 2016, AT
THE BASIS OF FOUR SEPARATE
APPLICATIONS.
EVEN McCABE ADMITTED IN SWORN
TESTIMONY, NO DOSSIER, NO
WARRANT.
THEY SAID IT WASN’T TRUE, IT’S
IN HIS TESTIMONY.
IN FEBRUARY 2018, SCHIFF
AUTHORED A MEMO CLAIMING THERE
IS ABSOLUTELY NO FISA ABUSE
DESPITE CONGRESS MEN DEVIN NUNES
WHO TOLD THE COUNTRY THE TRUTH.
DEVIN NUNES TOLD THE TRUTH,
WARNING THE COUNTRY.
HE WAS TELLING ALL OF US THE
TRUTH, THIS GUY WAS TELLING US
LIES EVEN WHEN HE HAD TESTIMONY
THAT WAS TELLING HIM THEY WERE
LIES.
THE DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL WAS
TELLING THE TRUTH.
STEELE DOSSIER WAS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION ALL ALONG, SCHIFF
LIED TO SOCIALIST COMRADES IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY LET
HELPED HIM LIE AND THE MOB AT
THE MEDIA ACTED IN P.R. STAFF.
THIS IS A REVOLTING BUT CLEAR
AND PRESENT DANGER THAT REMAINS
TO OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC,
THE RULE OF LAW.
EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS.
THEY MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THE DOSSIER’S CONTENTS WERE NOT
VERIFIED, HE KNEW HE WAS LYING.
THEY TOLD HIM IT’S NOT TRUE.
IT IS A DISGUSTING, DESPICABLE,
REVOLTING LIFE BY THE BIGGEST
LIAR WE’VE EVER WITNESSED.
EVEN CHRISTOPHER STEELE HIMSELF,
HE COULDN’T STAND BY HIS OWN
DOSSIER.
UNDER THE THREAT OF PERJURY IN
GREAT BRITAIN.
YOU HAD THIS CORRUPT
COMPROMISED, CONGENITAL LIAR
ADAM SCHIFF, WHAT HE IS DOING IS
A THREAT TO OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
HE WAS HELPED, THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA AND HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS
ARE COMPLICIT AND THEY WERE
COMPLICIT EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
INSTEAD OF WORKING TO COMBAT
GOVERNMENT ABUSE OF POWER AND
CORRUPTION, CHOSE TO ALTER HIS
OWN PUBLICITY AT THE RISK OF
INNOCENT PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES WERE
DESTROYED.
INSTEAD OF UPHOLDING HIS OWN
OATH OF OFFICE, HE LIED AGAIN
AND AGAIN.
IT WAS A CONSPIRACY THEORY TO
UNSEAT A ELECTED PRESIDENT.
AFTER THEY COULDN’T, PREVENT HIM
FROM GETTING ELECTED BECAUSE WE
THE PEOPLE DIDN’T LISTEN TO
THEM.
HE LIED ABOUT AN INNOCENT MAN
AND PROTECTED THOSE WHO WERE
TRULY GUILTY.
THEY WORKED TOGETHER, THEY
COORDINATED.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, HISTORY WILL
NOT BE KIND TO THIS PATHETIC